an alle
[Musik]
Frankreich bereitet sich auf
Stromausfälle vor die Regierung hat
einen Krisenstab eingerichtet bei uns
klagt der Einzelhandel über massive
Umsatzeinbußen vorneweg die Autohändler
spannende Themen heute mit spannenden
hier bei uns Ökonom und Autor Daniel
Stelter warnt vor der Wirtschaftskrise
und fordert genau jetzt
Steuererleichterungen Deutschland
verschläft seine Zukunft das glaubt Uwe
Hück früherer Betriebsratsvorsitzender
von Porsche und Europameister im
thayboxen ist auch noch und er haut hier
drauf auf Brüssel und auf so einige
Manager die so sagte unsere
Autoindustrie in den Abgrund fahren
Unternehmer und Fußballfunktionär
während Reisig ist entsetzt über die
Skandal WM in Katar und fordert harte
Reformen und mein Kollege Sebastian
Geißler befürchtet in Berlin handfeste
Randale der rot rot grüne Senat will ab
Januar Autoparkplätze für Fahrräder
freigegeben das alles jetzt hier bei uns
und ich habe sie bereits erwähnt
Frankreich Planet Strom Abschaltungen im
Winter die Regierung trifft dort jetzt
konkrete vorbereit sein arbeitet mit
einem Krisenstab an einem Plan Haushalte
sollen den Verbrauch senken so gut ist
nur geht bis zu sechs Millionen Menschen
müssen damit rechnen dass sie im Winter
zumindest zeitweise vom Stromnetz
abgehängt werden Frankreich plant jetzt
also konkret für den Notfall man rechnet
dort sicher mit Stromausfällen darüber
sprechen wir jetzt hier erstellter
Frankreich eine führende Industrienation
was sagt das über unseren Nachbarn aus
es sagte unsere Nachbarn aus dass ihr
einige Jahre lang nicht ausreichend
investiert haben in die Erhaltung ihrer
Kernkraftwerke die Kernkraftwerke sind
im Prinzip eine gute Idee sie haben aber
einige Jahre die Wartung nicht gemacht
auch wegen Corona und sind hinten dran
und das wird eben diesen Engpässen das
zeigt aber eigentlich nur symptomatisch
wie es Europa ist es ja nicht nur das
Frankreich schlecht Tasche oder andere
stehen schlechter und bei uns wir wissen
ja wir haben das Versprechen voneinander
wir brauchen die Atomkraft nicht wir
brauchen alles nicht alles wird gut ich
würde sagen es zeigt einfach die große
Risiken sind und mir wäre es lieber
unsere Regierung würde auch konkret sich
vorbereiten und würde vor allem noch
mehr tun ihm zu verhindern dass es
wirklich so weit kommt das wollen wir
alle nicht aber auch konkret vorbereiten
konkret auch mal warnen konkret sagen
das kann passieren fehlen ihnen solche
Warnungen auch hält ja vor allem der
Verstand der verstanden ist glaube ich
ganz arg wichtig um die eine richtige
Entscheidung zu treffen wenn ich
Politiker höre oder manche Manager die
behaupten dass wir bald nur noch
Elektroauto haben 40 Millionen Fahrzeuge
auf einmal sage ich mal in Ladestationen
dann wird aber die Lichter hier ausgehen
also Wasserstoff brauchen wir wir
brauchen sauberen Diesel da sind wir
einfach weltklasse und überall wo wir
Weltklasse sind sagt der Politiker das
wollen wir nicht und dann wundern wir
also ich bin da sehr ich bin da immer
ich wundere mich eigentlich dass sie das
Sagen und die glauben es auch noch und
jetzt wird es Zeit dass der Mittelstand
und und die Unternehmer jetzt mal laut
schreien und sagen jetzt ist aber feiern
die Schweiz hat heute auch mitgeteilt
Elektroautos wollen sie runterfahren
viel zu unsicher die ganze Sache jetzt
stellen wir uns nur einmal vor
Stromausfall sei es für ein paar Stunden
was bedeutet das für die ja
Automobilindustrie wenn da die Bänder
erstmal stillstehen ja vor allem
unabhängig vom Strom
wir sind ja ein
Industriestaat wir sind
Exportweltmeister gewesen und kein
Agrarland also wir machen nicht die
größten Kartoffeln das möchte vielleicht
paar Grünen aber das hat nichts mit
sozial
zu tun um soziale Marktwirtschaft zu tun
und ich glaube wir brauchen wieder
Politiker die erstmal in der erst mal in
der Wirtschaft gearbeitet haben um zu
verstehen was Wirtschaft ist die tun
Wirtschaft immer verwechseln da wo man
Birne trinkt das ist mein konkret bei
der Situation auch ich will sie
zuvorkommen lassen weil sie lachen
das Problem aber das haben wir auch
schon mal früher diskutiert hier der
Stelle wir haben das Problem einfach
dass die Politiker keine Erfahrung in
der Wirtschaft haben und darüber hinaus
auch meistens in Physikunterricht
vielleicht nicht so aufgepasst haben und
deshalb eben glauben dass bestimmte
Dinge einfach gehen weil man sich sie
wünscht aber es ist genügt halt nicht ja
was ich so wünschen und wir haben diese
Woche den Deal gemacht im Katar er hört
man die Kritik A 20 Jahre Vertrag ich
wette mit Ihnen heute in 20 Jahren
werden wir noch brauchen in Deutschland
und zwar deutlich mehr als Katar jetzt
gerade und uns verkauft hat das heißt
wir haben diese Idiotie zu glauben wir
könnten immereingang quasi uns völlig
unabhängig machen mit Solar und Winter
Sommer alles machen aber auch die
Mischung braucht man einfach
gleichzeitig die Energiebedarf
hochbringen normal das ist der am Ende
vielleicht eine zukünftige Welt gibt
eine Elektromobilität alles was
effizienter ist sondern es ist alles
gut möglich wir brechen es aber übers
Knie und wir tun immer so als würden
alle auf der Welt mitmachen und das ist
eben nicht so und ich will zu ihm sehr
spannend wenn man Automobilindustrie
betrachten die Chinesen da gibt es eine
Firma die kauft die Motorenwerke auf von
den Europäern die aussteigen und dann
sage ich mir immer ja gut warum kauft
ihr so eine Art Bettbank zu kommen wir
gleich noch spannend ich bin gespannt
auch Elektro aber die machen eben auch
weiter Verbrenner soll ich mir einfach
so was passiert da das werden wir ja
ganz ausgiebig gleich noch auf die
mobilindustrie das ist ja auch ihr Thema
heute mitbringen das besprechen wir
gleich noch ganz im detailreisig wenn
sie sowas hören von unserem Nachbarland
er wird jetzt konkret gewarnt stellt
euch darauf eine werden an Plänen
gearbeitet wie wirkt es auf sie haben
sie Angst haben sie Sorge dass es zu
Stromausfällen hier in Deutschland
kommen könnte sie sich da irgendwie
schon vorbereitet irgendwas im Keller
irgendeine Vorbereitung getroffen nein
ich habe keine getroffen und das ist ja
in der Tat so ähm der DR schneller das
eben schon angesprochen interessant ist
aber trotzdem und das muss man für
deshalb auch themaisieren das ist ja
immer gehiesen hat gerade in Deutschland
wir schalten die Atomkraftwerke ab oder
jetzt den Streit und die drei weiteren
Laufzeiten der Atomkraftwerke und jetzt
ist Frankreich hier eine wirklich
Atomkraft Nationen ja und ausgerechnet
die sagen jetzt wir kriegen riesige
Probleme also scheint Atomkraft
zumindestens nicht das Allheilmittel zu
sein wie das manchmal dargestellt werden
prinzipiell egal was wir diskutieren in
Deutschland wie diskutieren auf allen
Seiten nicht nur die von Ihnen genannten
grün sondern auf allen Seiten Fragen
viel zu ideologisch also ich würde mir
wünschen auf allen politischen Ebenen
dass wir mehr pragmatisch diskutieren
und uns wirklich auch an den Fakten ich
komme ja selbst drum ich bin heute aus
Spanien gekommen also auch dort die
Verhältnisse und das was wir besprechen
sind keine rein deutschen Phänomen wir
haben nur die Eigenschaft die Dinge
immer sehr dramatisch zu sehen also sie
wollen das Thema eher ein bisschen
runter kochen und denken Sie ich würde
gerne versuchen so in unityologisch wie
es geht die hier in unserem Land zu
besprechen mir ist einfach in all diesen
Fragen viel zu viel Ideologie bleiben
wir einmal noch pragmatisch Sebastian
bist du vorbereitet bereitest du dich
auf Stromausfälle vor ehrlicherweise gar
nicht man sollte das wahrscheinlich tun
in Wahrheit ist es so ich habe
wahrscheinlich nicht mal ausreichend
Tiefkühlpizzen da und wenn ich die hätte
ist die Frage was mache ich denn dann
bei der Elektroherd geht ja gar nicht
mehr
darauf
die meisten Menschen in Deutschland sind
darauf so nicht eingerichtet das kann
man als Privatperson auch kaum ich kenne
die Situation aus Südafrika wo ich seit
vielen Jahren oft Hinreise da gibt es
diese Stromabschaltung da ist es
tatsächlich so Südafrika sondern
schweren Energiekrise da wird dann
einfach mal als es von 16 bis 22 Uhr ist
der Strom weg wenn ich damit Leuten
telefonieren will in Kapstadt heißt das
ruf mich mal nach 22 Uhr und dann haben
wir wieder Strom Leute wussten sich da
aus mit irgendwelchen Batterien die sie
danach laden können
auch gesagt bereiten wir uns darauf vor
wenn wir so ein bisschen zurückgerudert
aber es gab ja zumindest mal die Aussage
kann nichts tun das stimmt natürlich
nicht sie können schon Vertreter haben
also sollten Wasser haben zu Hause
stellen Sie einfach dran ohne Strom
können Sie auch wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr spülen das kann auch unangenehm
sein also sie brauchen wasserverräte sie
brauchen etwas zu essen was sie sich
machen wahr machen können oder was eben
kalt essen können oder sie haben
irgendwie den schwereloskocher es gibt
für Möglichkeiten sich vorzubereiten und
was mir eher die Sorge macht für Sie auf
dem Land ist es noch vielleicht eine
mögliche Situation die eine über die
vertretbar ist aber einen großen Städten
weiß man ja von den Szenarien wenn dann
Stromausfall ein paar Tage andauert dann
herrscht
Probe
ist noch schön ausgedrückt wie viel Grad
haben vielleicht ganz kurz einhaken dass
man Sie vorsorgen soll nicht kommen von
der Stadt Pforzheim wir haben 130/100
unterschiedliche Nationalitäten 60%
Migranten wie sollen die Wasservorräte
oder Essen vor richtig vorsorgen es geht
gar nicht wir haben gleich die
Möglichkeit es sind drei Zimmer Wohnung
mit sieben Leute das funktioniert nicht
also ich bin der Meinung man soll also
wenn man jetzt mit dem Auto auf der
Autobahn fährt dann tut man sich auch
nicht vorbereiten dass jetzt der Reife
kaputt geht
aber jeder sagt ein und jeder denkt dass
er da passiert nichts also wir müssen
unsere Energieversorgung so gestalten
dass man uns nicht vorbereiten müssen
das wäre mir viel lieber ich komme ich
komme ja von der Auto Automobilindustrie
wir sagen immer das Auto muss so gut
sein dass man nicht reparieren müssen
und ich finde unser Staat hat die
Infrastruktur in Deutschland so
gestaltet dass man immer reparieren
müssen das ist der Unterschied wir
brauchen mal wieder Ingenieure also
Politiker die voraus denken
agieren und nicht klein laut denn die
und denken ja nur so weit bis die Wahl
kommt als zwei Jahre gewählt dann machen
wir wieder Wahlkampf das muss aufhören
wie ich meine es ganz offen sonst
schaffen wird Deutschland ab aber wir
schaffen wirklich Deutschland nicht mehr
interessante Politiker
eine neue Partei gegründet weil
Politiker ja ich bin auch ein Mensch
bin
nein nein das ist ja der Unterschied
dass ich ja ein Mensch bin der ja
pragmatisch ist der ja das sagt was
wirklich ist also ich bin vor Ort ich
habe eine lernstiftung mit 300
benachteiligen Jugendliche ich vermittle
sie in das Handwerk im Mittelstand also
ich werde es nicht nur von der Kanzlei
ich gehe tatsächlich dorthin wo es
brennt denn ich bin ein Feuerwehrmann
und ich bin meistens dort wo es brennt
in Deutschland tausende von Politikern
die Kommunalwahl den Menschen dran sind
dann müssen wir schon unterscheiden wenn
ihr immer sagt die Politiker haben ja
ich kenne hunderte die ehrenamtlich in
Kreistagen in wirklich in der Kommune
für die Menschen sind
zum Beispiel von Pforzheim nach
Stuttgart gefahren in Deutschland darfst
du gar nicht telefonieren wenn du Auto
fährst weil du hast überall Funklöcher
es funktioniert nichts in Deutschland
Digitalisierung funktioniert nicht die
Bildungssysteme funktionieren nicht und
jetzt sagen Sie immer das immer so
fleißige Menschen die alles machen warum
funktioniert bei uns nicht das wäre
ungefähr so als bei Porsche wir haben
bandmitarbeiter die sagen die sind so
fleißig und jedes Mal kommt ein Polo
raus kein Porsche ja also
ich habe nichts gegen Polen ich wollte
schon mal gesagt aber natürlich
unterscheiden auf welcher Ebene haben
ich glaube die Vermutung ist ziemlich
nah desto weiter weg vom Volk desto
problematisch hat die Politiker also bei
jedem vom Bundestag Bundesregierung wir
reden auch von den Ministerpräsidenten
und die Landesregierung zum guten Teil
die Aufgabe Problem nicht einfach nur
irgendwie zu warnen sondern tatsächlich
zu vermeiden
die Politik wir vermuten dass es nicht
genau aber sie tun kommt aus der
Wirtschaft und er ist gewohnt in der
Bilanz anzuschauen und die Bilanz hat
aktiver und passiver und der Staat hat
auch aktiv am passiver aber erstellt
keine Bilanz auf es gibt es in einigen
Bundesländern es gibt es auch Gemeinde
eben es gibt nicht auf Bundesebene hätte
der Staat eine ordentliche Bilanz
aufgestellt letzten Jahr und hätten wir
zwei Dinge gesehen zum einen dass die
aktive aktive abgewirtschaftet wurden
Schlaglöcher etc auf der Autobahnen was
weiß ich zu schreiben
und hätten wir die passive Seite geguckt
hätten wir gesehen der Staat gibt immer
ein Versprechen hier gar nicht
finanzieren
willst du denn da sind Sie mittendrin in
ihrem Thema der Stadt dem geht's gut und
den Bürgern genau
die Politiker machen nichts draus wir
müssen den Punkt mal ganz kurz
vielleicht erläutern also der deutsche
Staat hat genug Geld seit Jahren nimmt
uns der Staat immer mehr Geld ab und
zwar nicht nur absolut relativ so
Wirtschaftsleistung und gleichzeitig
haben die Politiker massiv Geld gespart
weil die Zinsen gesunken sind das heißt
sie hatten Hunderte von Milliarden sind
Ersparnis was haben sie gemacht sie
haben die Infrastruktur verfallen lassen
ich habe das Bildungswesen verfallen
lassen wir haben keine Digitalisierung
sie haben bei den Mobilfunk Option daher
kommt es übrigens mal die Einnahmen
maximiert und haben nicht sichergestellt
dass es keine Funklöcher gibt und
gleichzeitig haben sie im Prinzip Konsum
gemacht Konsum gemacht und jetzt gleich
fertig jetzt geht's weiter jetzt kommt
dieses Jahr heute und wir haben die
Wirtschaftsweise kommen und sagen den
Start geht super Gutachten steht drin
dass die Schulden des Staates in
Deutschland relative Wirtschaftsleistung
in diesem Jahr sinken werden warum
werden die sehen wegen der Inflation
weil die Wirtschaftsleistung monginal im
Geld hoch geht wir alle wissen es gibt
richtig hoch
Illusion geht hoch die Folge ist die
Schuldenquote geht runter die Verlierer
sind die anderen der Staat ist ein
inflationsgewinner und die Verlierer
sind die Bürger und die Bürger alleine
die Sparer haben viele Milliarden
verloren dieses Jahr nicht Inflation
4.700 € pro Kopf die Leute die Häuschen
gekauft haben verlieren weil die Zinsen
steigen und die hausaufreise
runterkommen das heißt wir haben das
Phänomen der Staat wird immer reicher
und die Bürger werden immer ärmer und
dann kommen noch was dazu wir sind
verglichen zu den Italienern sind
Spanier zu den Franzosen relativ zur
Wirtschaftsleistung und Europa und was
machen unsere Politiker und was sagen
andere Gutachten die gesagt hat der kein
Problem hatte wir müssen die Steuern
erhöhen und da frage ich mich habt ihr
sie eigentlich noch alle vor allem
Facharbeiter wollen wir anwerben was man
Ausland wir haben Ausland ist und guckt
wo kann ich hingehen der geht bestimmt
nicht in das Land der höchsten Abgaben
lassen das heißt der Staat muss auf die
Diät gesetzt werden damit die Politiker
gezwungen sind
mal richtig zu handeln die Politiker
haben zufrieden
gesetzt werden
die gesamtverstellung haben gesagt
Steuererhöhung sondersodium was weiß ich
völlig völliger Quatsch aber völliger
Quatsch kalte Progression muss ich
bereinigt werden
bei Porsche am Band steht der hat dann
ähm 300 € mehr Gehalt weil die Inflation
höher ist und davon nimmt der Status
weil die sachverständlich hat er gesagt
alles nicht machen der Stadt muss mehr
Geld der Staat braucht nicht mehr Geld
der Stapler bessere Politiker sorry auf
der Ebene des Bundes definitiv die sagen
moment mal wir machen nicht das nächste
schöne Gesetz mit großen Sozialleistung
und ähnlichem sondern die investieren in
die Zukunft des Landes und wir haben die
Zukunft des Landes haben wir eigentlich
abgewirtschaftet und er war zu
vorsichtig lieber gesagt hat und das ist
nicht nur die jetzige Regierung ganz
klar zu sagen das war seit 20 Jahren hat
man Konstanz gelebt und jetzt kommt die
Rechnung und jetzt brauche
ideologische Akteure die sagen
die Person Politiker sie oder wer ist
normal
Antworten okay ich nenne Ihnen keinen
Namen ich bin eine andere Antwort wir
haben die Politiker die verdienen warum
weil wir die Politiker mit ihren
Geschichten über ihre schlechten Politik
durchkommen lassen ich wollte wissen wen
sie verbessert finden wenn wir ich
möchte meine Aufgaben sind ganz andere
ich möchte dass die Leute im Fernsehen
zuschauen dass sie sagen moment mal ich
habe einen Abgeordneten ich würde gerne
Lösung ich bin jemand der gerne
ich komme viel in der Welt rum ich kann
Ihnen sagen dass in anderen Ländern
genau
den Eindruck dass Leute wie Sie und
andere auch Experten die ich sehr
schätze sie sind ein kluger Mann ja sie
schildern Probleme die sind übrigens
überall gibt wir haben gerade ein ganz
über Frankreich geredet ja so die gibt's
überall und ich frage dann kannst ganz
konkret wenn sie immer sagen die
Politiker dann sagen Sie mir doch mal
welche Politiker besser sind
sie haben gesagt
das Buch geschrieben
ich mache das kurz aber das ist ganz
klar wenn sie jetzt fragen von den
Parteien im Bundestag tut mir herzlich
Arbeit mir fällt keiner ein also seine
neue Partei nein nein ich möchte mich
schon gerne beantworten werden kommen ja
von der Wirtschaft und da labern wir
nicht sondern wir machens ich möchte
Ihnen gerne beantworten in der wenn sie
zehn die Bundesregierung bzw Bundestag
wo man haben sind die Hälfte ja nicht
gewählt worden vom Volk sondern von den
Parteien bestimmt worden also meine
richtige Politiker sind die vom Volk
gewählt werden die würde ich gerne haben
denn heute ist ja so du musst ja immer
wieder nicht so eine Partei sein um eine
gute Funktion beziehungsweise
Nominierung zu haben das müssten wir
abschaffen deshalb habe ich eine neue
Partei gegründet wo ich gesagt habe SPD
überhaupt nein Entschuldigung die SPD
der Gerd Schröder und ich wir hätten ja
wir haben vieles erreicht nicht
vergessen aber ich sie haben polemisch
gesagt und jetzt werden selber ganz kurz
ähm und darum sage ich sie haben eine
Frage gestellt die habe ich gerne
beantwortet und davon bin ich überzeugt
und jetzt gebe ich eine andere Antwort
das kann doch nicht sein dass die
Politiker sagen wir haben
Fachkräftemangel und schauen gucken und
jetzt nach außen außen wo können wir
Leute gewinnen für Deutschland und die
eigene Leute also Jugendliche Kinder die
werden vernachlässigt das sind Potenzial
ich habe so viele Jugendliche die die
eine die die eine Perspektive haben
wollen und die verlieren wir und da sage
ich da brauchen wir gerne Politiker die
sagen ich will dass unsere eigene
Jugendliche eine Perspektive bekommen
allein im Bildungssystem gibt es eine
Ungerechtigkeit da können sie sich nicht
vorstellen und hätte ich die also die
lernstiftung ich habe jetzt 300 ja wir
haben jetzt vergrößert noch mal um
dreimal so groß da immer mehr Kinder
kommen warum kommen die Kinder zu mir
warum kommen Sie nicht zu den
staatlichen Schulen da sage ich ganz
offen Dame unsere Probleme und wie man
jetzt nicht laut sind und klar sind und
sagen liebe Politiker es kann nicht sein
dass ihr ständig gewählt wird allen von
den Parteien nicht vom Volk die müssen
wir immer wieder so sehen
nein wir müssen die Parteien müssen wir
einfach klar und deutlich die Macht
entfernen lassen sondern das Volk muss
wieder das Sagen haben Friede
Bürgerbewegung für Fortschritt und
Wandel sehen wir die dann bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl jetzt weiß ich
nicht weil ich gerade vor Ort wie sie
oder Videos gesagt hast ich glaube jetzt
ein Boxkampf jetzt gegen franca wegen
meine lernstiftung ich kämpfe jetzt
gegen Tyson noch Ende nächstes Jahr ähm
weil ich das iPhone für wichtig finde
dass
ältere Menschen wie ich mit 60
Teilen okay
Gegner
warum mache ich das alles um den
Jugendlichen um euch alles zu sagen mit
60 bist du nicht am Ende sondern mit 60
fühle ich mich erst richtig wohl das
Leben an und mit 60 fängt glaube ich
auch europäischen Ländern
aber glaube ich eher der Steuersenkungen
also quasi dafür Entlastung nicht über
entlastungspakete sondern wie ist es mit
Leuten die zum Beispiel es gibt auch
Krisengewinner es gibt ja Unternehmen
die sogenannte übergewinne jetzt haben
damals
ist ja alles schön und gut ich glaube
der Punkt ist einfach wir brauchen Umbau
der Steuersystems also man kann
sicherlich muss man diejenigen der
arbeitet entlasten dass man definitiv
machen man kann auch darüber sprechen ob
man Vermögen höher belastet und so
weiter aber nicht einfach im Sinne von
wir machen das und top soll System oben
um einfach Arbeit attraktiver zu machen
das ist im Prinzip der Kerl da kann man
natürlich darüber nachdenken er müsste
auch die Frage aufwerfen warum müssen
wir immer in Europa der Zahlmeister sein
die kann man durchaus auch aufwerfen
weiß nicht im Weg verdächtig ist wer die
Italiener von mehr Vermögen haben warum
eigentlich ein Thema wie machen wir mehr
viel deutschen Vermögen da und dazu
gehört es den Leuten mehr Geld in der
Tasche zu lassen aber dazu gehört auch
die Vermögensbildung zu erleichtern
schauen sie wenn sie sparen sie sollen
sie sind sparen sie wollen Familie
gründen sie wollen möchten wohnen
Eigentümer werden dann müssen schon die
Grunderwerbsteuer anschauen
Hürden die das sind da müssen wir 1000
Euro in Berlin hat mal gesagt gibt es
eine durchschnittliche Berliner muss
glaube ich zehn Jahre alleine für die
Grunderwerbsteuer
der Multimillionäre zu haben wir da
nicht auch eine Verantwortung der
Umfahrt das kann man das kann man so
argumentieren nur wir müssen natürlich
einsehen ob wir wer die Frage ist haben
wir ungewöhnlich viel reiche also sind
gibt es bei uns sind bei uns die Reichen
reicher als in Italien Frankreich
Spanien das ist nicht so unsere reichen
sind nicht reicher so wir haben das
Wasser wir haben weniger gleich für
unseren Armen setzen und nicht mit den
Reichen
nein weil das Problem der Armen lösen
sie nicht wenn sie reichen wenn sie
reichen das wenn Sie die 50 reichsten
Deutschen Einheiten das ist ein
Bundeshaushalt das ist nach einem
Bundeshaushalt
100% teuer machen würden das heißt das
ist das bringt das hilft dem Arm dem
Arme wer war der Vermögenssteuer was
Erhöhung angekommen
Euro in altersvorarbeiten
können der Vorschlag wäre ganz konkret
wäre
jeder Bürger in Deutschland bekommen
35.000 Euro vom Staat in ein
alterssicherungskonto und dieses Geld
legt deutsche Staat der nicht der Scholz
selber Gottes willen sondern Fachleute
Profis so an wie das in Norweger machen
global angelegt in Wertpapieren
Infrastruktur global die haben 8%
Rendite pro Jahr und nach wenn er
niemals 65 ist dann bekommt dieses Geld
ausgezahlt als Zusatz für seine Rennen
aber für alle das war für alle Frauen
können sie hingehen können sagen dass
sie
Freunde
kommen nehmen Sie 5000 € besteuern
wieder einmal nicht weg das kann man
auch machen
Fußballspieler erfolgreiche Sprüche
natürlich nicht und das ist ja der
Klassiker jetzt das ist ein Vorschlag
der hat jetzt erstmal gut an ich kann
mich erinnern von ein paar Wochen also
ist diese 300 € pauschal gab war die
Kritik an den Politikern war die Kritik
gießkannten Prinzip das genau das
gleiche ist kein Prinzip also was ich
merke egal was in Deutschland passiert
wir sind die mecker Nation Nummer 1
da sind immer kluge Leute wie der DR
Stelter jetzt dieses haben dann
Vorschläge kritisieren dann zum Beispiel
das kieskrank Prinzip bei den 300 Euro
pauschalen ist für die Bürger gegeben
hat schlägt aber gerade für 25.000 Euro
auch ein gießkannten Prinzip doch sie
haben es ja gerade 300 Euro aber nein
aber wir müssen kündigen
öffentlichen Diskussion die 300 € extrem
kritisiert worden sind weil man
argumentiert hat dass das viele Menschen
gar nicht brauchen und nicht bei denen
man muss normalerweise aber das
gießkannten Prinzip ist ein Prinzip was
den Politikern vorgeworfen worden ja und
mir geht's um folgendes das weiß ich
nicht sagen
kommen
klingt ja alles toll klingt dafür auch
viel applausen verkaufen auch toll
Bücher aber es keine Lösung für
gesellschaftliche Probleme da sind
populistische Sprüche damit kommen wir
aber nicht weiter weiter kommen wir nur
damit wenn wir uns den Dingen stellen
und wenn ich immer höre ich mag einfach
prinzipiell nicht die Aussage die
Politiker er sagt ja er meint ja nur die
die über die Parteien über die
Landeslisten reingekommen sind ja aber
entschuldige ich gucke mir ja auch eine
Landesliste an und entscheide ob ich die
Partei will oder nicht so ist ja ist ja
nicht so dass ich die Landesliste vorhin
erzähle ich kenne den Spitzenkandidaten
kennen die Abgeordneten auf der Liste
drauf sind und dann kann ich mich
entscheiden ob ich denen meine Stimme
gebe oder nicht und im Umkehrschluss das
was du sagst heißt ja das alle die
direkt reingekommen sind über direkt man
da das sind die klugen und das sind die
allwissenden
Argumentation die über die Parteien
reinkommen nutzen uns nichts drauf das
kann doch dann auch für die anderen Geld
ich einen Vorschlag machen oder keine
Ahnung
ich möchte wegen der Steuersenkung
machen wie man ist Bürgergeld erhöhen
aber die gering für Diener nicht erhöhen
dann haben wir ein Problem das
lohnabstandsgesetz das bedeutet da
werden wir lieber wenn einer heute 2.400
€ verdient den kann ich nicht 3000 €
geben weil der Mittelstand kann das
nicht finanzieren aber die Steuern dazu
denken dass ich mich 700 Euro Abgaben
habe sondern vielleicht nur 300 Euro und
ich habe 400 Euro mehr in der Tasche
hilft der der arbeitet und die
Unternehmer das werden Vorschlag jetzt
einfach aber da gehen die Politiker
nicht hin weil die Politiker dann Pickel
im Gesicht kriegen wenn sie
Steuersenkung hingehen
lass mich doch nicht so aggressiv und
auch mal polemisch rüberbringen weil die
Menschen Menschen unter die 400 € gerne
gebrauchen können und jetzt noch zum
Schluss wenn die Politiker sagen ja die
Geringverdiener können ja auch zum
Jobcenter gehen und sich Wohnungsgeld
holen und so weiter ich finde jeder
Mensch hat eine würde die Würde des
Menschen ist unantastbar aber die
Politiker sagen nicht wie gucke ich dass
du mehr Geld kriegst sondern wie musst
du dann BITTE BITTE und das kannst nicht
sein und das will ich nicht und
vielleicht habe ich das vorher auch
überspannt drüber gebracht aber wenn du
eine Liste willst und das sind 20 drauf
dann findest du zwei gut und 18 scheiße
und du sie die 18 Scheiße mitnehmen so
einfach
das ist ja ein Thema nur dann lass uns
mal drüber diskutieren über das Bürger
hier damit spätestens eher sagen nee
funktioniert nicht weil das da geht's ja
auch um
nein
Automobilhersteller das tut mir leid
machen würde
wie kriegen sie Politik dazu dass das
viele Geld was sie hat in die Zukunft
des Landes investiert statt einfach im
Kopf zu Hause wie machen sie das denn
bitte also ganz im Gegenteil der Reise
kennt was ganz anderes gesagt der Reise
hat nicht mit ihnen ins gleichges blasen
und hat gesagt Deutschland ist scheiße
sondern 30 gesagt ich komme viel rum auf
der Welt und ich finde dass wir eine
gute Nation sind dass wir viele tolle
Sachen machen und dass wir in der Tat in
Deutschland auch Probleme haben die ist
gilt anzugehen aber dieses ewige mies
machen und erzählen dass wir im
schlimmsten 20 Jahren über Bildung
machen kein Fortschritt wir machen seit
20 Jahren
Infrastrukturen nein aber ich wollte
sagen
das werden wir jetzt leider an dieser
Stelle gar nicht ausdiskutieren können
und deswegen sprechen wir jetzt über die
Automobilindustrie da gibt's nämlich
auch nicht unbedingt gute Nachrichten
sie sagen ihre Kamera ihr Thema da
fahren wir gegen die Wand wenn man so
weitermachen unsere einzigartige
intergalaktische Automobilbranche
sage ich mal kaputt machen wollen dann
müssen wir diesen Weg weitergehen indem
man nur noch sagen Elektro Elektro
Elektro aber keiner versteht was ist
heißt denn Elektro wir haben erstens
adminfrastruktur nicht dann ist kobal wo
abgebaut wird gerade in Chile und in
andere Länder Menschen werden gequält
Kinder werden kaputt gemacht da sage ich
ganz offen Leute hört auf mit dem Moral
sondern wir brauchen mehrere
Möglichkeiten ah Wasserstoff grüner
Wasserstoff wir könnten unsere Motoren
halten wir haben geile diese Fahrzeuge
saubere Dieselfahrzeuge meinte ich jetzt
die sind weltweit die besten alles wo
wir sind wo wir gut sind sagen die
Politiker das wollen wir nicht
ebenfalls die sichersten sind ja in
Deutschland nach meinen Erkenntnissen
vielleicht liegt die auch falsch aber
wollen wir auch nicht aber den dreckigen
Atomstrom von Frankreich den wollen wir
jetzt kaufen und ganz teuer machen dass
die Menschen sich immer finanzieren
können darum sage ich wir brauchen
wieder Leute die kreativ sind die
Pioniergeist haben Pioniergeist heißt
was will ich neu ohne dass ich die
Menschen und den Staat schade ich bin
der Meinung und das ist meine
persönliche Meinung der die Politiker
die was zu sagen haben Schaden den Staat
mehr als helfen heißt das ganz konkret
auf die Automobilindustrie entzogen
sitzender
zu viele BWL hat zu viele Managertypen
und zu wenig
ingenieurekinger hat ja Porsche
erfolgreich gemacht weil er nicht ja
sage ist sondern weil er das gemacht hat
was er für richtig fand und wir brauchen
wieder Manager die einfach
Entschuldigung dass sie sagt wieder Eier
in der Hose haben zu sagen das will ich
machen und nicht ja sage und ich glaube
das ist überall
ja es ist abhanden gekommen weil man
nicht mehr gelernt haben zu kämpfen bin
ich jetzt mal Helmut schmitzi Helmut
kohlsee bin ich draußen sehe das sind
alles noch die Kämpfer gewesen das waren
die Camper die waren vielleicht nicht
immer astrein in der Aussage aber du
hast musst was sie gesagt haben
mit dem Diesel betrogen hat also der
irgendwie würfelt Millionen Menschen die
diese bedanken
nein das war porsche hat nichts mehr
nein war nicht doch
kein Verfahren
Leute richtig betrogen worden von einem
Unternehmen aber es sind immer die
Politiker und du tust dich sprechen
der hat Millionen Menschen ganz kurz
nein der hat mit diesem nichts zu tun
andere nicht beschuldigen es waren
andere ermittlungswerfer oder lief eine
eigene gesprochen worden hinter vorne
ich finde schade dass du Menschen etwas
behauptes was nicht stimmt wenn du
darfst das gegen Politiker ich kann es
ja nachweisen so ganz einfach haben wir
ein Bildungssystem so in Ordnung ist
haben wir eine gescheite autostruktur
bei uns haben wir nicht wir haben nichts
und jedes Mal behauptest du immer die
Politiker die sind gerade vom Herrgott
runtergeschickt werden
wir vielleicht noch mal ganz viele
abrunden ganz kurz Arbeitsplätze
befürchten sie da könnten
halbe Million bin ich mehr als überzeugt
der halbe wenn wir das so machen würden
wie
Ingenieure die nicht mehr Mut haben zu
sagen das geht nicht so und wenn man
einige Politiker haben die ebenfalls
sagen das geht nicht so wer mehr halbe
Million verlieren
überlebt Porsche Verbrenner gehen die
alle nach Hause was passiert genau alle
Bürger Geld bekommen
ich bin da muss ich sagen auch ein
großer Sorge wenn man sieht den
Niedergang von General Motors in den
Staaten wie Detroit im Grunde jetzt also
vollkommen runtergekommen ist da das ist
ja eine ganze Region die da vollkommen
verarmt ist wir haben bei uns im im
südöstlichen Niedersachsen habe ich
Familie die Arbeiten alle irgendwie bei
Volkswagen oder bei den angeschlossenen
Zulieferbetrieben wenn da der Ofen aus
ist oder bricht diese Region zusammen
Stuttgart zum neuen Detroit haben kann
ich auch nicht beurteilen aber was
natürlich ich ich was zu ergänzen weil
jetzt immer so sagen wir haben Sie das
Problem durchaus was Sie gesagt haben
dass auch die Unternehmen und die
Manager eben in dem Umfeld in dem wir
uns befinden auch die medialen Umfeld
sehr zurückhaltend sind und dann nicht
auf morgen die sagen halt nicht wir
besorgen uns mehr Lieferung gefällt
sondern die was sie machen ist die
Handeln einfach und ähm was Sie gesagt
haben schon vor Corona beispielsweise
konnten wir sehen dass die deutsche
Industrie abgewandert ist also der
Anteil der Wertschöpfung von
verarbeitenden Gewerbe sagt man dazu ist
bereits vor Corona gefahren und er fällt
jetzt natürlich beschleunigt durch den
energiepreisschock weiter und die Firmen
wissen wenn ich jetzt Manager bin ich
kann das hingehen kann sagen ich glaube
nicht an die Energiewende wie sie ist
dann werde ich da angefeindet was weiß
ich oder ich investiere halt nicht in
Deutschland investiere woanders und das
ist genau was passiert ich habe viele
Firmen schon einzelne nehmen die ihre
Firmen verkaufen die einfach aussteigen
oder die einfach sagen ich investiere
woanders die gehen die USA wo Energie in
Zettel kostet das passiert einfach und
wir haben dieses Klima und wir glauben
alle diese politische Klima das mediale
Klima und dann auch gesellschaftlich wo
man sagt okay wir wollen das alle oder
zumindest die Mehrheit haben die
Öffentlichkeit willst
es eben das halt Leute hingehen und
sagen Bruder Müller von der SBF hat er
gesagt moment mal hier ganz schwer für
den Standort da gab's recht richtig
Diskussion der will jetzt nur japanik
machen schaut immer die Gewinner an der
BASF die machen doch total viel Gewinn
ist kein Problem ja immer viel Gewinn
aber natürlich auch deshalb weil sie im
Ausland sind und jetzt was erwartet 30 %
werden sie in Deutschland abbauen und
das kommt noch nicht mehr wieder und
wenn Sie heute wenn es maßmännchen geben
wird die Welt es gibt chemische
Industrie noch nicht beispielsweise
würde sagen wo auf der Weltmarkt
chemische Industrie Thema garantiert
nicht auf die Idee ist in Deutschland zu
machen und das ist vergessen wir immer
wenn das immer weg ist es weg was
bedeutet das für uns was befürchten sie
wenn sie jetzt nicht glauben
aber das Problem es sind
überdurchschnittlich gut bezahlt
Arbeitsplätze und da strahlt halt aus
und wissen Sie wenn wir hinterher nur
noch ähm ich habe hier gesagt Cappuccino
verkaufen das ist zwar nett aber es ist
nicht so Wirtschaft und das ist das
grundlegende Problem und wir verkennen
meines Erachtens die Bedeutung die eben
diese Schlüsselindustrien für den
Wohlstand haben und wenn die erstmal weg
sind wenn sie kaputt sind sind kaputt
und das ist das was ich da bin ich
definitiv sehe als massive gefahren die
Unterstützung der Politiker das ist
heute glaube ich unser Liebling
also zunächst mal muss ich sagen ich
glaube seit ich denken kann höre ich von
Unternehmen die abwandern weil die
Bedingungen hier schlecht geworden sind
also das ist ja kein neues Thema
25 Jahren auch gesagt das wird jetzt
glaube ich spürbar und jetzt wird es
halt auch spürbar ich glaube das ist
dieser zu spät genau ich glaube ja das
ist diese Fälle gibt ich will ja gar
nicht schwarz weiß man sondern ich
glaube das ist in der Tat diese Fälle
gibt ja das ist auch BASF das habe ich
auch gelesen habe ich mich auch mit ein
bisschen beschäftigt ich bin jetzt so
drinnen in der Materie wie sie aber das
Argument das Unternehmen sagen die
Rahmenbedingungen werden schlechte und
wir gehen hier raus das hatten wir bei
der Frage des Mindestlohn all diese
Dinge wird es ja immer wieder
thematisiert diese Drohung ist ja nicht
neu also die kennen wir seit ist die
soziale Marktwirtschaft gibt so von
daher sage ich auch dort immer ein
bisschen Gelassenheit ohne das völlig
aus dem Auge zu verlieren aber keine
Panikmache von wegen die Großindustrie
und der Mittelstand
müssen okay
bin weil ich einfach
eingangs schon mal gesagt ich hatte
Eingang schon mal gesagt ich bin kein
Freund von den einfachen Lösung ich bin
kein Freund ich habe zwei Herrschaften
kommt doch mal runter entspannt
er bleibt mal ganz locker wird alles gut
werden ich bin kein Freund von
Populismus der das sind alles so Sätze
die hören sich gut an hier Steuer unter
jeder soll 25.000 € kriegen Freiberg für
alle findet jeder Klasse ich auch aber
ich sage im Kontext dessen was ich
beobachtete glaube ich dass wir viele
Probleme haben aber ich glaube dass wir
auch eine gute Nation sind und dass wir
stark sind und ich habe gesehen auch
unsere Vorgängerregierung das hat gar
nichts mehr jetzigen Regierung zu tun
hat uns auch durch einige Krisen in den
letzten Jahren durchgeführt
Energiekrise verschuldet keine kam dazu
aber es war gesagt wir sind das einzige
Land der Welt das aussteigt aus
Kohlekraft und Atomkraft gleichzeitig
und die ganze Welt wird uns freuen das
war Quatsch die Welt ist uns nicht
gefolgt
was mir nicht gefällt ist die
Unterstellung ständig immer es ist in
Deutschland erlaubt dass meine andere
Meinung hat absolut immer die andere
Meinung ist man nicht ein kaputter
sondern man hat es man und es nennt man
Toleranz
dagegen arbeiten
ganz einfach ich habe wir leben in eine
Transformation ich habe noch nie von
Abwanderung geredet sondern ich habe
gesagt die
Schlüsselprodukte wo man haben du die
Politiker kaputt machen also mit einer
sagte Diesel ist schlecht wir machen die
besten Diesel wir machen nicht die
Benziner die Benziner machen die
Osteuropäer das muss man einfach wissen
wir haben so viele gute Technologie
Antriebstechnik Wasserstoff seit Jahren
sagen wir wir wollen grünen Wasserstoff
haben dann kommt irgendein Prediger der
ist irgendwie ausgebildet worden von
irgendeinem Paps der sagt nee wir
brauchen Elektro alle gehen auf Elektro
die sind so der elektrolysiert das ich
sage nein und jetzt kommt vielleicht
Fehler
Auto ist kein Fehler aber zu 100 % ist
ein Fehler also wenn man sagt nur noch
Elektro ist ein Fehler das ist ein Teil
der Lösung ist ja das sind Teil
Wasserstoff ja das ist ein Teil Diesel
ja immer ein Teil sage ich und das muss
ich erst ergeben und davon habe ich
rohen Respekt dass man unsere gute
Automobilbranche kaputt machen aber
nicht kaputt machen weil immer dumm sind
sondern weil man das politische und die
Wirtschaft jetzt bin ich nicht polemisch
darfst du nicht politisch sehen sondern
betriebswirtschaftlich sind und das
machen wir nicht mehr und das ärgert
mich granademäßig und wenn ich manchmal
übertreibe mache ich das bewusst um
jeden mal das Licht anzumachen in der
Dunkelheit wo wir uns jetzt befinden
gar nicht mehr hören denn bald fahren
wir vielleicht alle Radl uh jetzt sind
sie alle still oha wären wir gleich hier
bei 8:15 Uhr kurze Pause bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein
ich finde diese Debatten unheimlich
wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ganz richtig was die Frau Wagner
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst dass wir zu wenig
Stadt haben wir haben zu viel Staaten
wenn die alle wegfallen und wir uns
gegenseitig in Berlin mit der
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand oder ist
alles Essig als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und Umgebungen von
Menschen unser Land fordert dann müsst
ihr bei euch anfangen da muss noch was
machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Gerät
[Musik]
wie sich vorstellen können wurde hier
auch in dieser kurzen Unterbrechung
Mutter weiter diskutiert und wir sind
zurück hier bei viertel nach acht ich
habe es gerade schon gesagt fahren wir
bald alle mit dem Fahrrad da wo das
plötzlich ganz still hier in dieser
lebhaften Runde ja der rot-rot-grüne
Senat der hat jetzt zumindest soweit
kommen lassen das ab Januar die
Fahrräder auf den autoparkplätzen parken
dürfen und das umsonst die
autofahrerseite zwei manchmal drei
manchmal 4 € und dort ein paar Stunden
zu stehen jetzt kann da in Zukunft ein
Radl stehen was das alles mit Berlin mit
der Hauptstadt machen könnte da hat sie
was länger mein Kollege große
Befürchtung also unglaublich das Berlins
Mobilität Senatorin wie sie sich an den
Bettina Jahres eine grüne
selbstverständlich was sie da macht sie
will dass Menschen ja ihr Fahrrad auf
dem Auto Parkplatz abstellen warum damit
natürlich die Autoparkplätze wieder mal
blockiert sind damit noch mehr
Parkplätze verschwinden
da wird ein Kulturkampf gegen das Auto
jetzt quasi zum Straßenkampf gemacht da
werden Menschen aber in
Verkehrsteilnehmer gegeneinander
aufgebracht dieser Senat schafft ihr
Probleme die sonst eigentlich gar nicht
da sind und hetzt eigentlich Berliner
aufeinander das darf nicht sein ich fand
mich mal Frau jarasch wie ist denn das
was sagen sie denn zum Beispiel der
Krankenschwester die abends vom
Schichtdienst kommt und die einfach nur
nach Hause und ins Bett will die dann
ewig irgendwie suchen muss nach einem
Parkplatz ja denn das sind die Menschen
wir normal Bürger die eben nicht
irgendwie ein tiefer haben Platz haben
oder so die das Geld nicht haben vor
Jahren nämlich das muss man mal sagen
lässt sich selbst um 7er BMW durch diese
Stadt kutschieren deswegen sage ich
dieser Vorschlag man kann sich schon mal
darauf einstellen das geht ab Januar das
muss gestoppt werden das Wahnsinn
mal an sie sind unterwegs mit ihrem Auto
vielleicht ein größeres ein SUV oder
sowas und wollen Parkplatz suchen
entsteht ein kleines Klapprad was machen
sie da nicht reagieren Sie persönlich
fahre nicht mit dem SUV in die Stadt
weil ich ja in Berlin wohne und vor dem
Hintergrund weiß dass wir es jetzt schon
abläuft also von dem Hintergrund mache
ich das nicht mit der U-Bahn in die
Stadt ich muss dazu sagen ich nehme als
meistens Carsharing das persönlich
fragen haben ja das stimmt aber das ist
manchmal sind auch sehr kompakte
Fahrzeuge sein Versprechen leichter ich
glaube der Punkt ist ein bisschen was
anderes ich glaube die Frage ist halt
immer wenn wir mehr öffentlichen
Nahverkehr wollen dann müssen wir mal
vergleichen wo läuft eigentlich gut ja
jetzt die sagen die Welt und ich muss
sagen also wenn Japan sind Japan fahren
ein Traum picobello sauber alles
ordentlich wir müssen gleich soweit
weggehen auch wenn sie nach Basel gehen
wenn sie dann öffentliche Nahverkehr
verwendet sind
automatisch ein
fahrscheinlich Nahverkehr nutzen
pickelbälle sauber alles auch in
Deutschland ist Berlin ist es vielleicht
nicht gerade das muss dabei Beispiel so
und natürlich hat man sagen naja gut
anstatt immer quasi was ist was jetzt
voll wenn der öffentlichen Nahverkehr
nicht attraktiv ist macht man die
attraktive wirklich unattraktiv ich
persönlich würde sagen lasst uns doch
den öffentlichen Nahverkehr Sorte tief
machen dass man freiwillig den nimmt und
macht das andere nicht unattraktiv und
das ist irgendwie
in Deutschland oftmals gerne gemacht
wird dass man im Prinzip teilweise schon
den zweiten Schritt macht vor den ersten
mir wäre es lieber man würde eben dafür
sorgen dass der öffentliche Nahverkehr
sauber und sicher ist und dass wenn auch
mal was passiert dass das irgendwie
später irgendwann mal dieses Video
veröffentlicht wird sondern früher auch
ein Großbritannien London wenn die Sonne
sind gibt's auch und sicheren
öffentlichen Raum aufgrund der
Videoüberwachung also ich finde das
müssen wir halt machen insofern ist es
einfach ein falscher Ansatz ich werde
Hals ist ja die ideologisches meiner
Sicht also ich finde die
Grundbedürfnisse der Menschen müssen für
staatlich werden also wie zum Beispiel
die ganzen Krankenhäuser die ganzen
Stadtwerke die ganzen Infrastrukturen
der der der Busse ich bin selber im
Stadtrat drinne dann werden die Sachen
ausgeschrieben wo keiner nachher
bezahlen kann
Stunde wie finden sie das jetzt am
Aktivisten auch gesagt wir kaufen jetzt
alle Gebrauchtfahrräder auf und dann
werden die einfach schön geparkt damit
dort die Autos keinen Platz mehr haben
ein Fahrzeug ein Q8 und habe aber einen
neuen Fuhrpark wo ich nur Smart habe das
sehen Sie hier zum Beispiel von meiner
Seite
nur für die Stadt da habe ich drei vier
Fahrzeugen leute kauft euch kleinere
Autos
immer vorsichtig sein dass immer die
Lösung die Lösung ist erstens ist es
keine Lösung die anderen zu provozieren
die Fahrräder haben und sagen ich tue
immer die Autofahrer zeigen wo es lang
geht umgekehrt aber auch wollen wir hier
Gewalt haben ich ich sehe das wirklich
man muss ein bisschen an meiner Sicht an
die Themen rangehen wo finden wir Lösung
für alle beide Seiten alle beide Seiten
müssen sich wiederfinden so ist es
wenigstens in der Wirtschaft wenn ich
verhandel mit dem Arbeitgeber muss ich
eine Lösung finden wo der Arbeitgeber
sagt damit kann ich leben und umgekehrt
wo die Arbeitnehmer und so müssen wir
mit den Radfahrer und mit den
Autofahrern eine Lösung finden aber es
kann nicht sein dass einseitig die
einfach sagen ich nehme die Gewalt in
Anspruch also ich tue einfach ein
Fahrrad hinstellen und wenn Sie das
Fahrrad wegnimmst dann werde ich
aggressiv ich will einfach das mal und
da sage ich da müssen die Politiker
einschalten und nicht sagen das lasse
ich mal laufen und wenn es dann schief
läuft so machen sie es ja leider
öfters dann sagen sie oh wie kann ich
die Leute bestrafen in Wahrheit ist es
ja tatsächlich so also was Frau Jahre
will ist das ist Menschen die eben kein
tieferagen Platz haben oder sowas
unmöglich ist als Privathaushalt
überhaupt noch ein Auto zu haben weil
kein Platz mehr das ist abzustellen
deswegen genau
die Regierung hat er schon track record
ich meine Friedrichstraße ist das ist
eine Straße wo wurde komplett gesperrt
für den Autoverkehr da wurden
umfangreiche Baumaßnahmen ergriffen
wurde viel Geld verschwendet und hat das
Gericht gesagt ist aber leider nicht
richtig wirksam aber das wurde alles
wieder zurück gemacht und die Geschäfte
sind aber ganz froh dass sie auch wieder
jemand kommt das war schönes Beispiel
oder mietendeckel anders erreichbar
aber der Punkt ist einfach der ist sie
sie könnten ja auch sagen wir schaffen
alle Parkplätze ab nein sie machen jetzt
im Prinzip machen sie die Aktivisten zu
ihren Handlangern um das durchzusetzen
und das führt zu einer gemeinsamen
wahnsinnigen Polarisierung noch eine
starke Gesellschaft und dann gucken
natürlich dazu führen dass irgendwann
mal Perspektive stand doch andere
Parteien antreten mit anderen Programmen
und das ist dann
irgendwann die Demokratie bestehen
bleibt wird es dann irgendwann da eine
Gegenreaktion gehen selbst in Berlin das
kann aber noch 10 Jahre dauern und
Finanzausgleich so großzügig fließt
dauert
fahren Sie dann einfach rum wenn ein
Fahrrad steht sondern sich ja gut okay
jetzt sind die Parkplätze auch fürs
Fahrrad die sind dahinter ist so sagt
dass man die Bürgersteige frei machen
will würden sie dann sagen ja gut
verstehe ich jetzt suche ich noch eine
halbe Stunde
verkleblichen Frankfurt da haben wir das
nicht ich finde auch der Ansatz ist
vollkommen richtig in der Kritik ich
glaube dass das ideologisch ist und
Ideologie schadet immer weil das Wetter
zu führen dass zwei Verkehrsteilnehmer
die Radfahrer und die Autofahrer noch
mehr gegeneinander ausgespielt werden
das ist schlecht
prinzipiell ist es so dass wir natürlich
gerade Großstädte verkehrspolitisch
komplett neu denken müssen das ist
einfach so dass das Setzen aus den 70er
Jahren übrig gebliebene setzen pur aufs
Auto in Großstädten nicht mehr
funktioniert das weiß auch jeder da
brauchen wir auch gerne drumherum reden
also müssen wir schauen und da stimme
ich ihn zu 100% zu der öffentliche
Nahverkehr muss wesentlich besser
gemacht werden wir sind in Frankfurt da
sehr stark ja also das funktioniert in
Frankfurt ganz gut aber wir haben in
Frankfurt auch Ideologien wo Straßen
zugemacht werden die überhaupt keinen
Sinn machen wo es wirklich nur um die
Gänge live und Autofahren also
ehrlicherweise
gerade zum Training kommen die möchte
ich endlich mal sehen ehrlicherweise
muss man sagen ich kann eine empirische
Forschung an mir selbst gemacht an und
ich bin ein absoluter Autofahrer ich bin
vor drei Jahren noch morgens zum Bäcker
gefahren mit dem Auto und habe die
Brötchen geholt also der Prototyp eines
wirklichen umweltschädlings gewesen und
habe aber durch diese Repressionen die
Frankfurt natürlich auch gezielt
verteilt gelernt mit öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln zu fahren und mit
Fahrrad so und jetzt sind wir beim
entscheidenden Punkt ich sage
selbstkritisch zu mir ohne dass man mir
permanent auf die Füße getreten wäre
hätte es nicht gemacht ich finde aber
trotzdem das Berliner Beispiel furchtbar
und ganz schlecht und glaube dass das
kontraproduktiv aber würden Sie Ihr Auto
aufgeben wenn sie so lange aber ich
merke jetzt schon ich habe früher eine
Laufleistung gehabt von 25 30.000 km im
Jahr ich bin im Moment bei 8 bis 10.000
also man merkt sehr deutlich dort wo es
einen guten öffentlichen Nahverkehr gibt
ist man bereit auch umzusteigen es gibt
für mich ich wohne direkt an der U-Bahn
es gibt 0,0 Grund für mich in die Stadt
reinzufahren mit dem Auto weil das nur
Schwierigkeiten macht und jetzt sind wir
bei fliegen halt lieber hin und her sie
sind schon Mallorca
aber das immer doch beim entscheidenden
Punkt und dann müssen wir uns doch
ehrlich mal ich fahre doch jetzt zum
Beispiel weniger weil man mich gegängelt
hat weil man mir gesagt hat
aber trotzdem aber wir müssen doch
trotzdem ehrlich sein wir müssen doch
für die für die Großstädte ein neues
Verkehrskonzept haben und das zumindest
mal neu denken
über Berlin weil ich mich da viel zu
wenig auskenne im übrigen
gesagt haben ich war vor vier Wochen in
New York weil das ist ja das Land der
unbegrenzte Möglichkeit da empfehle ich
ihn keine U-Bahn zu fahren ja ich musste
in der U-Bahn Station ein Cappy
aufziehen weil es von oben rein geregnet
hat also zum Thema
überzeugen sollten die Bürger
Single führt zu Aggression absolut nee
weil du gerade gesagt ich wurde ein
bisschen gegängelt um dann Rad zu fahren
ich bin der wir müssen mehr die Menschen
überzeugen diesen Mut muss man haben
diese Kraft muss man haben aber ich sehe
kein Politiker jetzt Leiter die jetzt in
Berlin sagen hallo Leute ich tu mal
meine meine Überzeugung mal erklären
in Ordnung
sogar Komplimente ausgeteilt also wir
können ja doch angesprochen
jetzt aber kommen wir zu Ihrem Thema
jetzt reden wir über die WM in catar wir
hatten hier auch waldemar Hartmann
sitzen er sagte lasst mir doch endlich
meinen Fußball den Fußball der muss
Fußball bleiben ich will keine Politik
auf dem Spielfeld sie sagen aber diese
WM die muss Folgen haben ihre Zeit ja
zunächst mal Waldemar hat man nämlich
sehr schätze das ist nicht sein fußball
ist unser Fußball also auch meiner und
der Fußball von vielen Menschen auch von
gleichgeschlechtlichen Menschen ist das
genauso der Fußball und es geht
natürlich darum dass wir in Zusammenhang
mit Katar nach der WM viele Dinge
aufarbeiten und viele Dinge diskutieren
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass wir nach
der WM eine Debatte kriegen ob die FIFA
so wie wir sie Moment erleben noch Sinn
macht ob das noch ein Verband ist den
wir brauchen ob wir nicht in der Lage
sind Weltmeisterschaften das ist ja so
die ureigenste Aufgabe der Fieber auch
anders zu organisieren ich glaube bei
dieser WM sind ganz ganz viele Dinge
schief gelaufen auch am Ende die Mund zu
Kampagne fand ich eher unglücklich wir
müssen und wir werden nach der WM viele
viele Diskussionen haben hätte man die
WM in diesem mehr als homophobenland gar
nicht erst veranstalten dürfen
also ich war ja selbst da vor drei
Wochen mit der bundesinnenministerin und
wir hatten Gespräche geführt und das ist
auch das enttäuschende Gespräche waren
sehr sehr gut aber es ist nichts
passiert anschließend es gab Zusagen die
wurden sogar schriftlich fixiert und es
ist danach ganz viel gehandelt worden
was nichts mit dem zu tun hatte was wir
besprochen haben ich glaube das Problem
fängt viel früher an es wird eine WM wie
in Katar wird so in der Form nicht mehr
geben weil die Fieber hat ja auch ihre
Regularien geändert und Menschenrechte
sind ja jetzt ein Bestandteil der
Kriterien aber
insgesamt auch das Verhalten der Fieber
während der WM diese one love-binde
dieses Thema das war ja schon der
abgeschwächte Kompromiss gegenüber
und dann wurde ausgerechnet die Fieber
ist dann noch macht den Diener von Katar
und verbietet auch noch diese Bilder
obwohl sie seit drei Monaten davon
wussten selbst in unserem Gespräch mit
Infantino war die Binde auch ein Thema
und da wurde das nicht thematisiert und
zwei Tage vorher wird das gecanceltino
viel viel Redebedarf haben nach dieser
Welt
auch Deutschland tragen sie sind
Spielerberater sie haben den FSV
Frankfurt in die zweite Liga
a Spieler haben die sich outen warum ist
das so ja weil es nach wie vor wir
dürfen uns ja nichts vormachen also es
bringt auch nichts wenn wir mit dem
Finger auf andere Nationen zeigen
natürlich gibt es bei uns im Land auch
noch Probleme jetzt sind wir wieder bei
unsere kerndiskussion hier ist auch
nicht alles rosig und jetzt auch nicht
alles gut aber der entscheidende
Unterschied ist bei uns können
homosexuelle Menschen frei leben die
brauchen keine Angst haben ich will nur
wissen warum ist es bei uns sogar warum
weil weil ich vielleicht noch Angst
haben weil ich vielleicht Angst haben
meiner Ansicht nach müssen sie es nicht
stören meine anderen müssen nicht ich
kenne auch einige und rede auch mit
ihnen darüber und aber es ist deren
Entscheidung weil letztendlich ist das
natürlich auch ein ungeheuriger Druck es
kommt ja dann immer dieses Argument wenn
du dann den Stadion einläuft schreien
vom Gegner 40.000 homo oder du schwuler
ja dann sage ich den immer das machen
sie auch so egal ob du schwul bist also
aber das ist ein verstecken
geraten sich zu outen so klingt so ein
bisschen ja auch so nein ich sage immer
also eigentlich Rat ist ich sage noch
warum weil das ist die schönste Zeit
deines Lebens also irgendwo wissen wir
alle zwischen 15 und 35 gut 59 ist jetzt
auch eine sehr schöne Zeit 60
entschuldigung aber
du verschenkst die schönste Zeit deines
Lebens mit dem Versteckspiel das muss
dir doch deine Seele zerreißen
und fragen Sie ich habe ich habe Leute
die mit mir darüber reden und ich
versuche denen das immer zu sagen ich
sage aber auch das ist am Ende deine
Entscheidung du musst das für dich
selbst entscheiden das kann niemand
anders für dich entscheiden oft ist es
so dass die in ihrem privaten Umfeld
auch geoutet sind aber eben nicht
öffentlich ich habe ja Kampfsport auch
so ich habe auch ein Fußballverein mit
800 Mitglieder gerade ein FSV Buckenberg
wo die meisten deutsche Aussiedler sind
da lerne ich dass sie Zivilcourage haben
aber von unserer Nationalspieler
verlangen wir das nicht ich erwarte von
denen dass ein Torhüter der schon alles
erreicht hat alles erreicht hat die
Bilder einfach dran ist und wenn die
FIFA mich bestraft weil ich da für bin
dass jeder Mensch so sein soll wie er
sich fühlt dann sollen sie mich
bestrafen ich war ein Kinderheim ich
habe 14 Jahre im Kinderheim und habe
acht Revolution geführt alle verloren
habe ich war wenigsten glücklich dass
ich sie geführt habe und das müssen wir
wieder lernen dass wenn wir unsere
Jugend sagen Toleranz ist wichtig für
uns
Respekt ist wichtig und hilfsbereit ist
wichtig das sind die Säulen des Fußballs
und das wird gerade eingerissen total
eingerissen nur wegen Katar das sage ich
ganz offen diese und Doppelmoral geht
mir wirklich an die Nerven vorbei zu
sagen guckt alle Fußball ne guckt kein
Fußball
so schlimm ist aber nebenbei tun man
dann Gas kaufen
unintelligible Tage raucht nicht und
nebenbei durch Zigaretten verkaufen das
geht nicht das geht und dann müssen wir
Klartext reden wir dürfen unsere Jugend
so nicht versauen und FIFA versaut
unsere Kinder und da sage ich jetzt ist
aber Schluss jetzt kriegen sie die Kante
vom Ausschluss es tut mir sehr leid ich
würde sie alle gerne noch aber ich bin
mir sicher hier wird noch weiter
diskutiert heute bei 8:15 Uhr ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich für diese
lebhafte Runde für diese interessante
Diskussion und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch bei ihnen fürs zuschauen
machen sie es gut wir sehen uns bald
wieder Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]